IT'S SAINT PATRICK'S WEEKEND!!!!!!
A time to celebrate the work of Saint Patrick
who converted the Irish from Paganism to Catholicism.
In America, this means getting medievally
blackout ffffffffffwasted!
Huh?
Howdy Irish and Irish-wannabes, Trace here
for DNews with some drunk science.
Now there's drunk, and then there's BLACKOUT
drunk.
Those are the times when you're so bombed
you literally have no memory of anything you
did or said.
A whole chunk of time is just lost.
Count yourself lucky if this has never happened
to you.
But why does this happen at all?
First let's talk about how memories are made.
Scientists aren't EXACTLY sure, but they THINK
it has to do with the hippocampus.
On a normal day, the synapses of your brain
communicate with each other to build your
experiences.
It's a chemical process pulling in information
from your senses, experiences and feelings
at the time all folded into the cells of your
grey matter.
Your cells communicate with each other using
a neurotransmitter chemical called glutamate.
Glutamate helps bridge the synaptic gap between
brain cells so memories can be stored and
accessed.
But alcohol is a toxin that affects the glutamate.
See where I'm going?
According to a study in the journal Alcoholism:
Clinical & Experimental Research functional
MRI scans of drunk students found our brains,
once intoxicated, increase blood flow to the
parts that control attention and cognitive
functioning as well as the parts that create
memory.
As the blood becomes more and more saturated
with alcohol, females will begin to black
out, and then males.
Blackouts start at a blood alcohol level of
around Point-One-Five.
During blackout, or a drug-induced brain dysfunction,
the hippocampus stops writing memories.
Basically, our 20-30 seconds of short-term
memory gets full and resets.
You didn't FORGET, you weren't even RECORDING,
dude!
You could ask a blackout drunk person about
a story from their childhood, but ask them
what happened a few minutes ago -- and they
would have no recollection.
According to Boston College, a blacked out
person is basically a walking, talking unconscious
person.
Sometimes blackouts let fragments of memories
through, but they aren't all the senses, thoughts
and experiences -- instead they're just pieces.
When we ask our friends, "What happened last
night" we are EXTREMELY vulnerable to suggestion...
Those memories were never written down, but
since the brain is a glutton for context you're
CREATING the memories from the stories your
friends are telling.
It might SEEM like a lot of people have blackout
nights, but only 40-percent of college student
have EVER blacked out.
If you DO experience them, you're more likely
to fall back into them if you drink heavily
on a daily basis.
Research from the 1940s found alcoholism and
blackouts were correlated, but there's no
causation.
Newer research says some people are more perceptible
based on body and brain chemistry, weight,
sex, and so on.
Anyone can have a blackout if they drink too
much, but if they happen too often, it can
mess up your brain chemistry and potentially
cause long-term damage -- not to mention the
bad decisionmaking.
If you want to avoid blackouts, don't drink
so fast!
Your body can metabolize one drink and hour
-- so get your buzz on, but don't get craazy.
Celebrate Saint Patrick's Day responsibly.
Sláinte, everyone!
What are you doing for the largest Irish-American
holiday?
Meeting up with other DNews fans to talk science
at the pub?
Tell us below, and subscribe!
Maybe you're drunk already!
If so, why not click the like button, you
liked this right?
Do you remember if you did?